- [Dan] I like,
I like the way they just.
I like the way they sink in like that.
Just slowly go down, it's like quick sand.
All right.
- Had to make a sound effect there.
What are you doin' Dan?
- Oh, just some bangers and some paint.
- Are they gonna blow up in slow motion?
Just throwin' out random guess, just.
- Pretty sure that's
what's gonna happen, yeah.
- [Gavin] All right, I'm
gonna put the lights on.
All right.
Gonna film this paint on the
1610 at 1500 frames a second.
Should be slow enough
to see some glass goin'
all over the place.
- I should think so, yeah.
Okay, ready?
- [Gavin] Good Lord.
- That literally got me
straight in the face.
I was like, little pussy little bangers.
- [Gavin] So Dan.
- [Dan] Oh yeah.
- [Gavin] Slight modifications this time.
- [Dan] We've made a
sort of makeshift holder.
Nice order there.
- [Gavin] Good order, it's a new order.
- [Dan] POBYGR.
- [Gavin] That's your
favorite saying, isn't it?
- POBYGR, yeah.
Or RGYBOY .
No, it's RGYBOP.
- [Gavin] I like the
fact that you said RGYBOY
which means you thought
that was called yurple.
- I was like think fast,
think fast, RGYBOY.
Bop .
Look at the back of this jacket.
- [Gavin] You all right?
- [Dan] Yeah, just tons of
glass right in the back.
It's fine.
- Well that quite.
- Yeah, I really liked
how all the paint exploded
in a different way.
- [Gavin] Made a dog's
dinner on the ceiling.
Look at that.
- Oh yeah that's a nice little bit of art.
- I've never seen the
initial explosion that slow.
- No.
- That was 15,000 frames.
I mean, usually the paint is
slow 'cause it's slowed down
but that was cool to see that.
- It was interesting to
see how some of it exploded
and some of it just went straight up.
- Yeah, some were rockets
and, ah, bloody nightmare!
Look at that.
I'm gonna put this in
the wash immediately.
- I've got hair in my
paint, hair in my paint?
I've got the hair in my paint.
See ya guys.
- [Gavin] Taxi.
- [Dan] Look at that.
- [Gavin] Oh, it looks
like you've been shot.
- [Dan] Look at that!
- Flip!
Jesus!
- [Destin] Oh look at
your camera, oh my gosh!
Oh crap!
Jeez!
- [Dan] Oh my gosh!